No. Welcome to another Zoom call. We're trying to answer the questions. Make sure, if you understand, you can chat in your questions
from this point on. Otherwise, if you have questions, make sure you go to the member site
and there's multiple places where you can answer your ask your Zoom call question.
Okay, let's get to the first question. My oncologist has told me at least five visits that my MRI results would probably be better
if I would just take to Moxifit. I listened to your videos regarding that drug and chose to take them. You sell. I take two caps a day. Do you think that's equivalent to taking the drug?
No, I don't think it's equivalent. I don't think there is a natural equivalent to taking to Moxifit, which is an aromatase inhibitor, which effectively completely shuts off all your estrogenol, your hormones.
So there isn't a natural way to do an aromatase inhibitor as well as the drug will do it. And that's why so many women would choose to go the natural way
because they don't want the same exact effects negative effects that would happen if you took the drug and why if you just want to shut off all your hormones, why don't you just take the drug?
Well, because I don't want to shut off all my hormones, I just want to shut off, you know, the negative, the quote unquote bad estrogens, I don't want to shut down all my estrogens and all my progesterone and all my testosterone is shot and I just feel like horrible and I have all these symptoms.
I don't want to do that. Okay, well, then if there's not going to be a natural thing that's going to do that as well, if there was, you might as well just take the drug.
So the effective demand and so for a faint and I see three and different products that are natural aromatase inhibitors is going to be much more gentle, it's going to be milder.
So if your purpose is to really, really shut down all your estrogen in your body and really help with estrogen receptor or progesterone receptor or who to positive cancers, then you just might as well take the medication.
But so many people choose not to do it that way, want to do a natural way and can have you won't have the exact same effects, but you'll have the same or similar outcome.
And that's the goal, right? You want to have the same outcome.
So the only way to know if you're going to have the same outcome is, unfortunately, through trial and error, that's just the way life is we don't know unless you can show, let's say, let's say I'm going to do a natural approach, I'm going to take them and other natural aromatase inhibitors.
And then I do a MRI in three months and my cancer is worse that I can choose to do the to mocks if I can choose to go a heavier route.
Well, why don't I just choose to do that first? Well, that's a choice of person, many people, most people do make, but then if that doesn't work, then they may be done damage to their body and they have some regrets.
So it's kind of like my comment has been over the years of like, okay, should we just hit it hard and heavy, my cancer is heavy as I got because that's many times you'll hear that an ecologist will make that statement, you have this cancer, they'll give the diagnosis, and we're going to hit this with all we got to kill the cancer.
Well, I'm not saying that can't be effective. That's like saying we have a sniper in New York City, so we're going to nuke the whole city.
There's going to be a lot of collateral damage to hit it hard and heavy hit it with all we got.
There's going to be collateral damage that goes along with that and are you willing to do that collateral damage.
That's not always even, whether you're even willing to risk that or not, you got to look at is that wise. Sometimes it might be saying it's not, but is it wise for you?
You're going to make that decision.
Concerning metastasis of cancer to the lungs.
So first as breast cancer metastasis lung liver cancer colon cancer metastasis the lungs, I've heard that breathing in alkaline water can help alkalize or destroy the tumors in the lungs.
Do you have any suggestions about how to do this?
Yeah, don't, don't do that. You breathe in alkaline water, you'll drown. So that's not a good thing to do.
It's not the alkalinity that is going to kill the cancer to the lungs.
The cancer in the lungs, I would suggest hydrogen peroxide and use the hydrogen peroxide protocol that is on the whole page of the member site.
And use nebulized hydrogen peroxide.
If you debilize alkaline water, you're not getting the alkalinity from the water, so I would not do that.
You can't breathe in water, you will drown.
So you can't nebulize things, you could nebulize a liquid corniceps, but I don't know how much corniceps you're getting through a nebulizer.
I think your best chance is to try to kill directly as nebulized hydrogen peroxide.
Hydrogen peroxide is an oxidizing agent that if you could get it to the cancer directly, you could kill the cancer.
So that would be the best route, not alkaline water.
The naturopath is recommended managing my groin pain by using steroids.
It is not her preferred method, but nothing else has worked at eight months.
An unceasing pain has left me debilitated and worn out and unable to function in the day and unable to sleep at night.
Is it safe to try steroids with bladder cancer and with a low dose of either dexamethasone or hydrocorrosone will be suitable?
Well, I can't tell you about the dose, but I do agree with your naturopath.
So if a person cannot overcome their symptoms through natural leads in their symptoms are debilitated, that's what medication steps in.
So, you know, don't be afraid of doing medication.
Do you need chemotherapy when it's appropriate?
Do you need a rheumatic inhibitor when it's appropriate?
Using natural pain or using medical medication, pain medication when it's appropriate?
Just do things when it's appropriate.
If you give it eight months, it's a pretty fair shake of doing everything you possibly can to overcome your pain.
If you're not sleeping, you're not going to have a good immune system.
You're going to have a much more difficult time to overcome your disease.
If you don't get your sleep and you're in constant pain, so I would say yes.
The doctor talked to your medical doctor about the dosage of the friend of his own.
Of course, just mention to your doctor, as you want to start with the lowest dose, hopefully they're willing to work with you whenever you need to.
From the chat, my last MRI is showing the following.
Right, retro, krull, lymph node, structure measuring, point seven is noted.
What is this means and where is this?
Yeah, so, and comparing to a previous, if you could just send me the MRI and then maybe schedule a time to talk, that would be the best thing to do.
And hopefully this is a comparison to a previous one, the oncology or the radiologist should have done that.
If so as well.
Would you use a nebulizer for hydrogen peroxide?
Yep, that's, that's what I said. You use nebulized hydrogen peroxide.
What is the dosage and how often?
The dosage is on the home page of the member site.
There's a recipe for nebulizing hydrogen peroxide.
It's a Dr. Mercola document.
You have to follow that recipe exact to water down the hydrogen peroxide to the percent that you want to use in a nebulizer.
So, how do you dilute the hydro peroxide?
Follow that recipe and you make the, you make your solution following that recipe.
Put it in a little squirt bottle and then make enough so that you could use it for a week.
And you could do it several times a day so you can nebulize that solution that you've created.
Following that recipe, that's on the member site, the home page of the member site.
Follow that recipe, make your solution and then you could nebulize that two or three times a day.
So, that's how you would do that.
Yes, no, it's not regular hydro peroxide, it's food grade that must be diluted.
So, follow the recipe that's on Mercola's habit on there.
So, there is no previous lift to compare.
This is the first one.
Send me the MRI so I can look at that please.
Many patients choose to an operation to remove the tumor and often is a part of alopathic standards of care.
Once the tumor is suspect, lymph nodes and suspect lymph nodes are removed and there's no visible cancer left.
In my case, colorectal tumor, I understand my next step possibly of circulating to ourselves instead dealing with circulated to ourselves and stem cells.
I'm not that interested in prophylactic chemo approach.
Stop there a second.
So, what when a surgeon does a debulking of a tumor, let's say they debulk the tumor, let's say it's a colon colorectal tumor or something.
And they remove that section of the colon and they say that they feel like it was completely attacked that they has spread beyond that.
There's no visible spread via a PET scan examination.
There's no visible spread via MRI or CT scan.
Blunt test look normal.
Let's say it's a breast cancer.
They remove the breast.
You do a vestectomy.
There's no visible spread.
There's no metastasis that's present.
Therefore, you're quote unquote cancer free or quote unquote no evidence of disease.
Why would people struggle with why would an oncologist then recommend prophylactic chemo beyond that point?
Why are you asking me to do chemo when you would you say that there's no evidence of disease?
Would you say you've got it all when the surgeon was confident that they got it all?
Because the oncologist understands that long before even you were diagnosed with cancer, your tumor was giving it off circulated tumor cells or what are called cancer stem cells.
So those still are present.
And in order for cancer to be picked up on a PET scanner or a CT scanner MRI, it has to be three to five million cells large.
So the person may already have metastasis that doesn't mean that it's going to turn into full blown cancer at that place.
Might be a couple hundred thousand cells large and your immune system that might be effectively killing it, but it might not.
So could chemo help with prophylactic chemo help in that case the answers.
Honestly, yes, it could, but a lot of people don't want to do that because that can also knock down your body and can knock down your immune system
because all sorts of other issues that maybe are not appropriate for a person who's struggling with cancer can't I try to kill this in other ways?
Yes, that's what you're that's why you're doing the right. That's why you're doing all these other things.
Finish a person question as such what blood tests or other tests do you recommend to determine the extent of these cells, the circulated tumor cells and the cancer stem cells in the body?
And what are typical Connor's clinic approaches to reduce or eliminate these circulated tumor cells and stem cells?
What are possible ways forward to deal with this from your holistic perspective?
So that's the benefit to me. That is the that is the benefit of a natural approach.
Well, how do you, you know, take a cancer that's trying to set up home or raise a family of tumor cell circulating in your body trying to set up home or raise a family elsewhere, other than the primary tumor site.
AKA, how do you prevent metastasis?
You have to stimulate that person's immune system do everything you possibly can and use use frequency technology using right technology right technology is not going to just hit the primary cancer.
It's going to hit that cancer anywhere it is in the body.
Well, if right really works, why didn't it take care of the primary tumor and just make that disappear? Well, a lot of cases it does and a lot of people it does.
But lots of times remember, you're dealing with a tumor that's multiple centimeters large.
The immune system to try to get in there and kill it. Those are millions and millions and millions and millions of cells. It's difficult. It's difficult.
That's why I've always said from the very beginning of ever doing cancer work. It can be beneficial to debulk a cancer.
And by debulk, it means to remove surgically removing or chemotherapy, removing a good portion of the cancer.
So it gives the immune system a better chance to kill small tumors, maybe even smaller cancers than are able to be detected on a PET scan smaller than three million cells large.
I think your immune system can kill a cancer that's that's two million cells large.
Is it easier to kill that or kill a cancer that's 40,000 million cells large.
You know, think of it as it's what's going to be easier pretty common sensical right.
So if we took away a lot of the burden the larger mass of the tumor surgically if that's possible.
Then it's easier for my immune system to clean up those other things. So I would highly suggest that you continue your natural approaches as best as possible.
To answer the question as what blood tests can be done to determine the extent of these other tests.
Those that report to do a circulated tumor cell test would say you should run circulated tumor cell tests.
There are blood tests on the market that are circulated tumor cell tests.
Why don't you advocate for circulated tumor cell tests, Dr. Colors. The reason is is that it's only measuring the amount of circulating tumor cells in the blood sample.
Okay, you might show zero circulating tumor cells that doesn't mean that you that you have it given off circulated tumor cells sometime in the past, which everybody with cancer has.
And that those kids those cells have set up home, but are trying to raise a family and deliver it in the logs and in some other organ.
You can't measure that. So the only way they're had you measure the extent of circulating tumor cells into your body. No, the only thing you could measure is the extent of circulating tumor cells in that blood sample at that given time, which to me gives you really no real data that can really help you.
If it's zero, you have zero circulated tumor cells. Wow, that's great. Well, yeah, that's better than having circulated tumor cells in the blood, but it still doesn't give you any data on circulated tumor cells that have migrated to other tissues and are starting to replicate or have yet to replicate in other tissues that are sitting dormant in your liver that are sitting dormant in your log that doesn't give you that data.
And there isn't any way to measure that there's no medical way to measure that and tell the cancer that circulated to yourself and starting to replicate and is replicated beyond three billion cells large, then it'll be picked up on a pet scan.
Even if it starts to replicate in your immune system is keeping it at bay, there's no way to measure them. So probably the best way to measure this point.
If pet scans are clean, MRIs are clean, CT scans are clean. How do you monitor this patient then? Well, to get follow the oncologist recommendation to get follow up MRIs or CT scans or pet scans that are reasonable to you and be measure tumor markers, do a tumor marker test.
Yes, well, my pet, my tumor marker tests don't show positive, so, but so, well, good. Let's just keep that monitor. That's a cheap inexpensive non invasive way to measure if, you know, something jumps up.
And if you never showed positive tumor markers with your cancer that doesn't mean that a metastasis wouldn't show positive tumor. So that's the best way to measure it.
As far as a natural approach holistic approach is everything you're currently doing. Remember, you just removed the largest burden. Now your immune system can focus on any cleanup data, any cleanup information.
Think of a burden that was on a person's immune system when the tumor was large, not to say that we haven't had people and lots of people have, you know, have experience of the tumor shrinking even if it's large, but some people it doesn't and then debugging it is the way to go take that burn it off the immune system so that now you can focus on getting rid of this stem cells and such.
I met with my functional doctor today and she was curious as to why you recommend that I go completely off of iodine since iodine is frequently recommended with breast cancer. She is not advocated for it, but simply would like to know your mind on it.
So the only time I recommend iodine for breast cancer, if with physiology, it tests well with them. And typically it's only for a relatively short period of time being on iodine long term is going to cause issues with the person's thyroid gland.
Well, the time we're going needs iodine that's part of the thyroid hormone it is. You get a plenty of iodine from your diet in order to deal with all access iodine.
Access exogenous iodine is going to be very attractive to the thyroid and is well very commonly and that causing a Hashimoto disorder, which is an auto immune thyroid issue.
So, you know, you have to be careful with iodine. I know that there's books. I read them. Books written on iodine and breast cancer. Every breast cancer person should be on iodine.
I just don't think that that's correct. You have to read the studies of what iodine exogenous iodine does to the thyroid gland. You don't need coboridities of that as well.
What's the difference between doing a Dutch test and a saliva hormone test get from ZRT? So a Dutch test is a dried urine hormone test. The saliva test is usually a different hormone.
So it depends on what you talk to. So there's advocates to the Dutch test that say that's the best way to measure hormones. There's advocates to the saliva test. There's not very many advocates anymore that the saliva test is a very accurate way to measure hormones, but the real controversy is between a Dutch test and a blood test.
So a blood test can be even a little more accurate than the Dutch test, I think, except the blood test doesn't typically measure all the intermediates.
The Dutch test, I think, is accurate. I don't think the saliva test is a very accurate test.
However, let's say the person has done saliva hormone testing and they're retesting. Well, then maybe stick to that and continue to do the saliva testing. You can't compare urine test to saliva test to a blood test. They're going to be a little bit different.
So whenever you've done its best to stick to it, I prefer the Dutch test because of the intermediates and everything that a test or the cost of the test, I think it's the best test.
I don't advocate for the saliva test for core bones, but the blood test, you could have argued that that could be a very good test too.
Do you have any experience with the test for a vial, which takes blood, stool, and saliva, and is supposed to tell you what foods to eat, recommend supplements, and probiotics.
No, I'm not familiar with that test itself. It's, so no, I guess I can't answer that. I'm not familiar with that test.
I live in Iowa in the midst of severe flooding in the past month by 21 year old son has been doing cleanup, taking out docs, deconstructing buildings, cleaning out toxic, moldy sewage-filled basements.
His boss advised him to get a tetashot. I believe the tetas vaccine is only available in a DPT. He has had no vaccines ever.
What are your thoughts on ways to protect against tetas and what are some mantra ways to boost and protect your body in such conditions?
Yeah, I am not in favor of getting the vaccine. I'm not in favor of getting a tetas, even if you're exposed.
I know that you're going to possibly be exposed to tetas. There's also, there's a giant discussion involved in that.
The good websites to go to about vaccines would be vaccine awareness. I forgot the name of it. Robert Kennedy's website on vaccines can be beneficial.
The best way is to boost your body is through protection. So you boost your immune system to immune stimulants.
And he's got to be wearing masks and clothing and things, particularly with moldy sewage-filled basements.
The best way to protect yourself is through protecting exposure, giving yourself barriers.
What are some reasons the young adult might be experiencing hair loss? Is this typical thyroid or adrenal related, commonly thyroid?
Can I ask that? If you have questions about family members and such, maybe ask the questions on our holistic health hour, go to holistichealthhour.com and ask those questions.
So we can keep these questions related to people with cancer that are part of our program.
Most common reasons for young adult experience hair loss would be thyroid issues, so getting a blood test for thyroid would be a problem.
During our appointment, you recommend I go off. I don't know completely. Why is this inside and it's completely okay? So I answered the question.
Post chemo, the PET scans, CT scans show no tumors in December.
The oncologist wants me to do another PET scan CT scan, however my insurance has denied the PET scan.
My oncologist has suggested two CT scans instead, one of my neck and one of my chest. I've been told that CTs are more toxic, less effective than PET scans.
Is this true? It isn't worth fighting my insurance company for a PET scan or are the CTs sufficient?
Why they can be better to get a PET scan? So I think it'd be worth fighting your insurance company to get a PET scan and then try to stick with PET scans.
The struggle is if you have certain insurance that's just going to refuse PET scans all the time and they're not going to let you do a PET scan, this is probably a six-month PET scan, then it can be difficult in the future.
So again, you're trying to measure apples to apples at all things when you're doing subsequent tests. So if all you're going to be able to get in the future is a CT scan, then maybe you just go ahead and do the CT scan.
I don't remember off the top of my head the difference in the amount of radiation in a PET scan versus multiple CT scans, but CT scans are area specific.
So your oncologist is right if you're going to look at multiple areas you have to get multiple CT scans.
My functional doctor for some reason doesn't like Dutch tests but prefer saliva ZRT. Are you aware of something I can send her to persuade her to go with the Dutch?
Yeah, I don't know. I mean, there's probably tons of stuff on the Dutch website. Of course, you know, they, you know, of course, they're trying to sell you on the Dutch test. So I know that it might be biased, but I'm pretty sure that they have some research on the Dutch websites.
And I'm sure no, maybe it's not ZRT. Maybe it's doctor's data has a Dutch test too.
So yeah, I don't know. I don't know why your doctor likes maybe your doctor just does the ZRT.
It doesn't have an account with precision analytics. I don't know.
So yeah, and if you, so you must be, though, I don't think you're the one that asked the question about the Dutch test versus the ABR.
But if you've had Dutch tests in the past, I'd suggest that you stick with it. If you've had again, if you've had the salivary test, then maybe just continue with that.
Would it be a good idea to do blood tests for my hormones in between Dutch tests? If so, I am by yearly gyroclogical visit next week, and they may be willing to run them, which tests do I ask for?
Well, you ask for a complete hormone panel. And certainly, if you're going to get blood tests anyhow, and if your insurance is going to cover it, get everything you can possibly get.
To make sure you're getting a CBC in a complete metabolic panel and ask for two or more tests to be run, and you know, ask for everything.
If your insurance will cover it, that's the best way to go.
One of the tubes that connects my rifball to the box was accidentally pulled out several months ago.
I put it back together with electrical tape that it's been working.
However, I have concerned that it might not be working correctly. I've not wanted to go without my rif, but should I send it in to get fixed?
If so, how would I go about doing that?
Not sure by what you mean the tube.
Are you talking about the cord that plugs into the rif machine?
So the rif machine is that little box that says true rif on it, F122, and you plug red to red, black to black, with your bulb.
Is it that that came out and you taped it back together?
I'm not sure what you mean.
So you have to get a little more specific for me to answer that.
If the bulb is still working, that's a good sign it's probably fine.
It's, you know, if it's as long as it's working, it's not a problem.
The only thing is if you have a faulty connection and it's not working all night and it's shorting out or something like that, you could possibly damage the machine if it's the cord.
So, yeah, I don't know.
The thing to do though, if you're having issues like that, the black tubes that connect the bulb to the machine.
So again, are you talking about the wires?
There's, there's no tubes that connect the bulb to the machine.
If you're talking about the wires that connect the bulb to the machine,
you, you may want to take a picture of it with something with a fix like that.
That would have to go through a true right.
I don't have the capability of the soldering.
They would probably tell you to buy a new bulb.
They may want you to send pictures.
That would be the most appropriate thing to do.
It's hard to explain those these things verbally.
So, they may want you to send pictures so I would call true right.
I sent it a question last week.
I know you're on last week, but it doesn't seem to appear here.
I asked about info on MECFS where my right machine.
I also cannot seem to find very recent old recordings.
I assume they were deleted from your YouTube page.
No, they're all, we got YouTube back up and running completely.
So, I don't know.
I'll have to look if there's.
Credit fatigue stuff on the right or not.
I can look tomorrow.
And see and.
And remind me, hopefully, Marie, if you're on the phone, if you're about to get back to.
To her tomorrow.
But only as far as going to the old recordings of the of these zoom calls.
They are on YouTube.
But all the YouTube recordings of the zoom calls are not public.
So you would have to go to the member site.
So you go to the home page of the member site.
And then you go to the zoom page.
So the page that says zoom calls.
And on the zoom call page, you scroll down and you'll see.
Past zoom calls.
And then you follow that link to past zoom calls.
And you'll be able to see all the past zoom calls.
So member site zoom call page.
Scroll down.
Past zoom calls.
And.
You'll be able to see it on YouTube.
We also have our.
Content up on our non YouTube video channel.
So wherever YouTube has been giving us all these problems.
Dustin and I discussed and he came up with the idea we set up our own video channel separate from YouTube.
So we created our own video channel separate from YouTube, which is videos dot colors clinic dot com videos dot colors clinic dot com.
And they're all on there too.
So all our videos are duplicated YouTube takes down my videos.
Like every week it says YouTube to be deleted.
Delete in your video.
I forgot to get one just.
Maybe for yesterday, which one did they delete?
What was it again?
Um, let's see.
YouTube.
No, I'm curious.
They.
YouTube removed your content.
Oh, cancer Q&A with doctor cutters.
17 minutes in your video.
They said something that helps people with cancer.
So they deleted the content.
So.
Yeah.
So here's the link.
I don't think everybody can see that.
So.
And then videos at cutters clinic dot com.
You'll see all the YouTube video all our.
Videos up there as well.
Just search.
Zoom call in the date you're looking for.
If you just search zoom call on the videos at cutters clinic dot com.
Videos dot colors clinic dot com.
You'll come up with all the different calls with the dates.
Um, yeah.
And if you have trouble with that, don't.
You know, you call the opposite.
If you need to as well.
So.
All right.
Any other questions?
I guess I'll back to my garden.
Tending.
And I know multiple people I'm asked to share some.
Videos and pictures of my garden.
I will do that.
Some time.
I'll put it on the member site for people to see to.
And.
Thanks for being on.
We will talk again next week.
Which questions in and know that I love you all.
And I pray for all of you.
Have a great week.
Bye.